I'll give you a head start up of that
let's appreciate that what's wrong one
lap no hits tour I've never been at this
racetrack before seven tips it's cool
that we can do all the NASCAR stuff with
the NASCAR expansion for four to six but
people in all sports you know they're
thinking about like what would it be
like if Michael Jordan played LeBron
James or babe ruth get to you know go up
against barry bonds or whatever it is I
think the equivalent of that in racing
is like what if these in stock cars had
to had to race against Formula one cars
Indy cars supercars you know you can
actually kind of live that fantasy in
this game yeah that's pretty cool
especially going to race tracks too I
don't think NASCAR or many of the
drivers haven't seen for so that's
that's pretty sweet but that's what's so
cool is that like I can still play you
know I don't have to be a professional
that's right yes art you know what are
the times when your car would be a
better option versus when you know you'd
rather be in a Ferrari or a Formula One
car against I'm like a Ferrari or
something I think my car would be better
on oval tracks ray but the Indy cars
they're gonna be faster every time yeah
yeah they're just built for that dress
they're building way faster and way more
aerodynamic break Greg yeah yeah that's
me crashing into people now that was
good you know I came out of the way all
right i'll take that right bad at all
thank you i think i actually have a way
to to make it a little bit more of an
even playing field I got a Neff one car
Oh a handicap the ring well you've
guessed Wow shores is faster so
are you the gas is on around the wall I
just want to like give you a nice little
head start no I'm like a straight away
cuz my car is superior to your car right
now coming for cars flying coming for
you [ __ ] oh I'll thank you wreck
yourself haha oh I felt like you were
pointing with me so now we got the
NASCAR versus an exotic the cover car
for four to six is the 2017 ford GT
you're gonna be driving that all right
we're driving lamaze by the way which is
pretty cool because ford's coming back
yilmaz this year you know yeah that's
pretty cool the GT looks pretty 6 all
right here we go ready I think that you
have NASCAR events at evelyn's at they
definitely different I'm opposed to
hurry into it now explain to me how that
car feels you know it's a manufacturer
but it's a completely different feel
right oh for sure it turns differently
brakes differently I think I was a lot
better in the stock car yeah I try to
get like a photo finish going but I just
had to thanks for uh thanks for throwing
me a bone